make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys we are
continuing the Batman whoo laughs and I
know if you guys can tell but I am not
feeling very good right now what to
Wrestlemania which was awesome got
caught in the rain storm afterwards
which was not awesome it's over the last
couple of days I have had like a stuffy
nose and a sore throat and I've been
coughing up some delicious lung butter I
am under the weather so videos will be
scant this week uh there's this video
today
they'll probably one on Saturday and
then we'll have like a video on Monday I
think
and then hopefully by Monday we'll be
back like hopefully by the weekend I'll
be feeling better we can you like get
back to normal uploads if not well
they'll be scant until I feel better so
anyway uh Batman whoo last part for okay
so this story actually kind of takes it
in same turn and it's kind of funny
because people were kind of getting a
little irritated it was taking so long
to come out but one of the things you
guys need to bear in mind is that DC's
actually slowed down their releases
they've decreased the number of books
that are coming out and they've also
slowed down how often those books are
coming out so it's one of those things
like sure they're trying to sort of
navigate the waters on new how come a
book should be distributed and so on
it's always an ongoing process it always
happens every I don't know every five to
ten years you know it's always something
along those lines that sort of sees a
shift but the fact remains that that
initially was picks up and it's kind of
cool
is remember Batman had basically
ingested like the Joker toxin right like
turned himself into the Batman who lasts
because from his perspective and the
advice of everybody around him it was
the only way he could really win and so
one of the things that it kind of does
is that with him sort of ingesting this
this substance and then going through
and kind of musing to us for a minute
one of the things that he says is that
when he is whatever he's going through
and things get tough right like things
get hard what he tries to do is see the
world through the eyes of like the
Robbins of of Jason Todd and Tim Drake
and and Dick Grayson and Damian Wayne
now he says seeing the world through the
eyes of the Robins but he refers to them
as his children and so really seeing the
world through their eyes kind of allowed
Batman to see innocence to sort of move
away from the perspective of like the
world is dark and dreary and everybody's
bad and seeing it from the perspective
of hey like sometimes people just trying
to do their best but like not everything
is so so black and white as adults
really tend to see it there's a lot of
different shades of gray there cuz it
was kind of cool because following this
you basically pick up with Alfred who's
just now realizing what Batman has done
and this is actually a really really
cool exchange and the way the Scott
Snyder does this is really nothing short
of amazing because the way this plays
out is Alfred freaks like Alfred panics
right because for Alfred is like one of
the worst case scenarios and really
contextual II speaking given the current
situation it is the worst case scenario
I'll
it's fear is that Batman will be lost
forever that's the biggest thing that he
goes through and literally like Batman
says hey look I have this visor on
because it allows me to differentiate
things that was kind of cool because
initially we didn't really know what the
function of the visor of the Batman who
lasts we don't really know what his
purpose was honestly I always thought it
was just kind of for visual effect and
what Batman actually tells us really
Scott Snyder kind of says here is that
the visor serves a purpose that what it
does is it kind of allows the Batman who
lost to filter through all the different
wants and desires that people have but a
person can use it for a variety of
different ways the Batman who last uses
it in order to determine what people's
most violent desires are Batman can use
it to see what they're hopeful desires
are so busy kind of allows you to see
the the desires the wants the needs of
anybody that you look at and so when
it's taken away from Batman it's kind of
like his only real weapon but from the
perspective of Alfred it's like we'll
know I'm trying to keep you from
completing your desire to be the Batman
who lasts like it's not a really a thing
that you need it's the thing that you
want because you're becoming the Batman
who lasts and it's kind of a cool thing
because where Batman tries to reason
with Alfred Alfred and turned like smack
him across the head with it and this is
cool because what it does is it turns
into a knock-down drag-out fight between
Alfred and Batman who as this plays out
like literally Alfred is beating the
crab like beating the crap out of Batman
and then Batman is not doing anything to
stop him because he knows that the
reality of this is that it's kind of
coming from a place of love but as he
looked at bat looks at Alfred what he
sees is that where Alfred says hey look
I love you he sees like you know kind of
what the the venom is wanting him to see
which is Alfred wants to hurt you he
wants to bring you harm you have to get
rid of him you have to kill him and it's
kind of crazy because he sort of goes in
like this ran in tears Alfred and where
he's like all you've ever done is pulled
me back I've carried you all this time
like literally spewing out every ounce
of vindictiveness and anger that he
possibly could and that's really kind of
the nature of the toxin is that while it
sort of twists you out as a person and
it really kind of kind of real warps
your perspective it brings out all this
anger and all this wrath because in
reality it's almost like Batman's being
deprived of something that he feels he
needs one of the things that I hope you
guys are noticing here is this really
seems to be a pretty strong allegory for
like drug addiction and is it is kind of
crazy when you look at it that way like
when you sort of shifted up drug
addiction alcoholism things like that
like things that people are addicted to
you that negatively impact themselves
and the people around them and that's
why it's kind of crazy because Batman's
kind of lashing out at Alfred like you
don't want me to succeed you don't want
me to
to been if you want me to do well all
you want to do is hold me back yeah and
all these different kinds of things just
spilling out anger but it's not really
Batman talking it's literally the the
talk should kind of talk to you through
Batman's robbing his mind to a place
there doesn't really have any have any
reason to go to it so again what's
Batman sort of regains his sanity kind
of comes back you know really sort of
returns to himself so apologies are
given back and forth between himself and
Alfred and Batman basically explains
this is what I have to do because
there's no other way that I can win
there's no conceivable way that I can
beat this guy and now the cool thing is
that following this where Batman that's
kind of racing through the city it gives
us a chance to sort of see how this
visor impacts him right like when he
goes through there and he uses this
visor he looks around and he sees like
people who were hopeful like basically
like good people he sees their dreams
what they what they look to aspiring uh
parents who hope their child becomes
something great in the world but then
like what he also sees is the darker
side people who want to murder each
other who want to like pillage and
destroy each other but it's kind of a
cool scenario where the spies are
working the way it does and with the
nature of Gotham City the question I
would pose to you is which one of these
is the truth the version we're like
Batman sees hopeful people or the people
who were violent and destructive and
just want to kill everything which one
of these is true when it comes to the
realm of Gotham because Gotham is a dark
and violent place and it's kind of
interesting because it's kind of Scott
Snyder sort of asking that question like
which one of these is real like which
one of these is the actual real place
now at this point we actually switch
over to Commissioner Gordon his son
right like we switch the switch over to
James Gordon jr. and again we talked
about him in previous videos that James
Gordon was a legitimate psychopath but
with Batman bringing him out as kind of
using his mind to kind of predict where
the Batman who last will go kind of
using a crazy person to predict a crazy
person more or less but as he's talking
to James you know one of the things that
James asked it or really kind of makes
us this argument on his Batman's no kill
rule and one of the things he says is
that back when he was a psychopath and a
serial killer that he was kind of like
the no kill rule is stupid because like
we're all Batman really seems to do with
his no kill rule is give criminals a
second chance but he's giving criminals
a second chance to commit crimes the
only way to really deal with criminals
and to get rid of them completely is to
kill them a dead man cannot be a repeat
offender and it's kind of a cool thing
because when when he says that it's sort
of hey look like this is how I view the
world
I thought your no kill rule was stupid
because all you were doing was just
basically letting criminals back out on
the street you had this sort of you know
really hopeful gosh golly they'll weep
it one day you know kind of kind of
belief system but it never did any good
you were a gerbil in a hamster wheel you
were just running in circles hoping
things changed one day if you run long
run hard enough but they never really do
but what he also says is at the same
time one of the things that I've learned
is that there are people out there who
deserve second chances it's not that
clear-cut
not everyone deserves a second chance
but not everyone deserves to die for
what they did but you kind of have to
take it on a case-by-case situation what
he asks is he says hey look I know what
you're trying to do here and I get where
you're going with this
the question I have is what's the Batman
who laughs is defeated and when you
defeat him do you have a failsafe do you
have a way to bring yourself back and to
basically cure yourself of this joker
toxin and Batman doesn't answer and so
the implication seems to be that know
that once he becomes the Batman who
laughs there's no way to undo this so
he's going to be stuck this way the fact
remains that what this ends up doing is
kind of switching to like three hours
product and we have this awesome this
awesome cyber that takes place between
Batman and Joker and it's so cool
because when Batman spins around it
starts talking to Joker like any kind of
hallucinates that like Joker wants to
kill him and so on and so forth but what
the Joker says is like I'm just here to
talk and when that mess are asking
questions like Goodyear's want to talk
you want to laugh do you want to see
like that you finally got what you
wanted the Joker says no this is not
what I wanted I did not want you to
become the Batman who lasts that if
anybody's gonna kill you I want it to be
me more so than that like you and I are
intertwined forever like it's kind of
crazy because it's like we are sort of
irrevocably tied together right like you
know I'm the the Clown Prince of Crime
like I'm the ultimate evil you try to be
the ultimate good even though you're not
really and like we fight against each
other and that's basically it
but he basically says that like this is
really the only way that you could win
Riley this is the only way that you
could possibly pull it off but you know
I believe that one day like I will kill
you and that will be the end of that but
until that day comes I came here to
simply tell you good luck and it's kind
of interesting here because what Batman
does is he addresses the Joker and he
says look the people in my life like
Alfred will not have the cojones to do
what it takes right like if I full-on
become the Batman who laughs like if
there's no way to bring me back from
becoming the Batman who last
Commissioner Gordon Alfred like none of
these guys will have the to have the
balls to do what it takes so I need you
to do that and the Joker says yes if you
become a Batman who last I will kill you
it's a mercy killing it's really Batman
like relying on the Joker like I
wouldn't go as far as you say like they
become friends but they become more
allies than anything else so again by
trying to track down these these portals
trying to try and track down these
sources
Batman is out travelling the Blackgate
prison to the section that was really
more like a transition period right like
it was basically like a halfway house so
to speak which we knows being brought in
and then being sent to Arkham Asylum and
so as he goes through here he ends up
running into like this one cop you know
who's kind of like hey look you're the
Batman who laughs I'm gonna blow your
head off
and that unbasic aliy reasons with him
he kind of reveals information like his
wife and his daughter his daughter has a
little little bit a little Batman doll
that she squeezes and at last which of
course Batman never laughs Batman
doesn't like the fact that it last it's
always kind of like hey look that's how
you know I'm Batman because I don't
laugh you know and it is it is kind of
funny it's kind of a cool little thing
but still like as he goes to this portal
he ends up in this version of Blackgate
that's six times the size of the one in
the main DC Universe and we end up
finding out that in this one particular
universe in the dark multiverse that
this version of Arkham Asylum is ran by
Bruce Wayne himself and in this moment
like when he starts addressing him and
saying hey look like you're in danger
people are gonna come for you they're
gonna try to take you and they're going
to try to eliminate you again we don't
really know the reason why these
different Bruce Wayne's are being killed
being taken and killed but we do know
Batman's trying to save this one and in
that moment they're yanked back and the
main DC Universe and where Batman tries
to take this version of Bruce and
basically hands them over to to this
competence they look keep an eye on him
make sure nothing happens to him and
then in turn deals with like the other
officers who were showing up we end up
finding out this cop is not actually a
cop instead this cop is the Batman who
lasts and that's crazy because basically
like it's set it's set Batman up and
it's kind of a cool thing because what
he says is like I know everything that
you're going to do that man who laughs
knows everything Bruce Wayne is going to
do and that's the difference here is
that Bruce Wayne is basically like he
transformed himself into the Batman who
laughs but he's not actually thinking
like the Batman who laughs he's thinking
like Bruce Wayne as it was basically
Snyder kind of saying hey look you're
really gonna have to give yourself over
and become this dark and sinister
version with a tiny ounce of yourself
governing your actions in order to fully
be able to defeat this guy otherwise
like there's no real way for you to win
and so what the Batman who laughs does
masquerading as this cop as he tells all
the other officers that Batman is that
Batman who laughs he basically killed
Bruce Wayne he's got a trigger device
he's gonna blow himself and everybody
else up kill him take him out now and
all the other officers around them
opened fire on Batman but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explain make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Laughter]
[Music]